a couple of weeks ago I did a segment
where I told you that I had really been
sort of feeling down about the state of
affairs of American politics so much so
that I started kind of questioning is it
time for the David Pakman show to end
have we sort of done everything we could
do and that's it and it's time to hang
it up and ultimately I decided that no
way this is the worst possible time to
scale down and in fact we should really
be thinking about how to scale up
because we are at a time when
independent progressive need media is
arguably more needed than ever before
sort of sort of in the modern
independent media era and if it's been a
couple weeks now since that show and
I've been thinking about okay well if we
want to scale up what should be the next
thing what should be the scale up
because we've already done so many of
the things that we can do right growing
the show from once every other week to
daily expanding the staff to to
full-time producers upgrading equipment
improving graphics adding new
distribution platforms all that stuff so
to figure out what we should do next
I really just went back to what are the
most common complaints about the show
and I don't mean like hatred type
complaints obviously personal attacks
like I'm a Jew [ __ ] all of that stuff
those are some of the most common
complaints but what I mean is
constructive criticism right
constructive criticism and ideas from
our core audience and from our affiliate
television and radio stations and the
core complaints summed up basically are
not enough shows commercial breaks are
too long right I'm gonna deal with the
two complaints individually but I see
that as a good sign that the primary
complaint from our core audience and our
affiliate stations is we want more
content from you both in each show and
on a month-to-month and year-over-year
basis so let's first start with more
shows per year right now our limitations
are basically staffing limitations right
when we're on break there are no shows
because everyone takes vacation at the
same time we don't have sort of like two
sets of staff where we can wrote
vacations so the solution is we need to
add another person to the team and the
program started as just me then we had
me plus a part time producer then years
ago the position formal formerly held by
producer Louis went from part-time to
full-time then we added another
part-time producer which became a second
full-time producer at the beginning of
2018 so the next step is we add another
part-time position with the idea that if
things go well and we continue to grow
that position would become a third
full-time staff position on the show in
addition to me and that person would do
many things very important things but
one thing that they would do is learn
how to produce the show which would let
us start to rotate vacations Pat can go
on vacation and the new producer can
produce the show with me hosting Pat
comes back I can then go on vacation and
we can have a guest host host the show
with Pat producing and we've had a few
different guest hosts over the last year
we've got another one scheduled that you
will be meeting in the next couple of
weeks but the idea would be to have a
rotating cast of guest hosts and this
would allow us this is no joke this
would allow us to add about 25 shows per
year which is if you think about it on a
yearly basis that is a huge increase in
the number of new shows that we're going
to be able to produce and that's without
anybody losing vacation time which is a
really important thing to me as people
who watch the show listen to the show no
that's initiative number one secondly
let's talk about the commercial breaks
historically we used to have mostly like
long term advertisers sort of like
foundational underwriters that advertise
with us for an entire year at a time and
we still have some of those they're
different on the radio show on the
podcast different versions of the show
the show is a one hour show on broadcast
radio and TV so that's sort of like the
maximum time there's 60 minutes in an
hour corporate news hours are often 37
to 38 minutes we started with a 45
minute hour which was already a longer
hour
most corporate shows we then expanded
that hour to 49 minutes an hour some
time ago don't remember exactly how long
ago and because of the really great work
of producer Noah who's been working with
advertisers we are now in a position to
be able to cut a bunch of those ongoing
advertisers basically just say hey you
know what we are ending your sponsorship
of the David Pakman show which will
allow us to add time to the show because
most of these new advertisers are only
on our podcast and our YouTube channel
which is not restricted to an hour or
per show so what we're going to be able
to do with just a little bit of a push
is pull off some of those advertisers
and add that time directly to the show
which is going to give us about a 10
percent 10 12 percent longer hour every
single show how are we going to do this
am I going to do an IndieGoGo campaign
am i doing a membership drive is it
gonna be patreon the answer is no it's
actually gonna be much more simple
my goal is add 500 new paid supporters
to the show and in the past we've had
the problem where I do a membership
drive and patrons get upset or I talk
about YouTube's sponsorship and members
say I just signed up for membership and
now I don't count towards your new goal
so we are going to be in keeping with
the mo of the show
I am completely agnostic as to which
platform you use to count towards these
500 supporters the goal is 500 new
supporters and we're going to be
tracking this and there will be three
ways to help us three ways to count
towards that 500 number today is the
baseline today we start at zero option
number one become a member okay you go
to david pakman.com slash membership
monthly membership yearly membership use
the 40% off coupon code if you want
which is vote soon 18 which you can
enter on the second page of the signup
lots of great benefits including the
bonus show the commercial free audio and
video streams every new member at
whatever price counts towards our goal
of 500 new financial supporters second
method
counts just as much patreon how much do
you have to donate doesn't matter a
single dollar contribution counts as a
patreon donor at patreon.com slash david
pakman show and it counts towards the
goal of 500 new supporters also a lot of
really great perks on patreon and the
third option this is something new
perfectly welcome as well YouTube
sponsorship were part of a YouTube beta
for sponsorship which is $4.99 a month
it has its own set of benefits which
include a sponsors only icon next to
your name and comments and Chad sponsors
only posts you will see on the david
pakman show youtube channel as well as
on the video pages a sponsor button not
everybody will see it because it is in
beta sometimes you have to reload
there's some algorithm that determines
whether you see it or not but that will
also count to towards that 500 new
supporter number so membership patreon
YouTube sponsorship doesn't matter which
you do this will allow us to hire a new
producer create a new position to serve
as a backup producer 25 extra shows a
year shows will be 10% longer we also
will be able to with this new producer
to expand the show there's like three to
five new platforms that I would love to
be putting our content on but we're
simply maxed out right now with current
staffing so there is a lot we will be
able to do if you want more show help us
get to these 500 new supporters I will
update you tomorrow as to how it's going